Elon is an interesting case so you are a
proponent you celebrate Elon but he's
also somebody who has for a long time
warned about uh the dangers the
potential dangers existential risks of
artificial intelligence how do you
square the two is that a contradiction
to you it is somewhat because he's very
much against regulation in many aspects
but uh for AI he's he's definitely
um you know a proponent of of
regulations I think I think overall you
know he saw the dangers of say open AI
you know cornering the market and then
getting to have the Monopoly over uh the
cultural priors that you can embed in
these llms that then you know as as llms
now become the source of Truth for
people then you can shape the culture of
the people and so you can control people
by controlling LMS and he saw that just
like it was the case for social media uh
if you shape the function of information
propagation you can shape people's
opinions he he he sought to make it
competitor so at least like I think
we're very aligned there that you know
they the way to a good future is to
maintain sort of adversarial equilibria
between the various AI players um I love
to talk to him to understand sort of his
thinking about uh how to make you know
how to Advanced AI going forwards I mean
he's also hedging his bets I would say
you know with neuralink right I think if
he can't stop the progress of AI you
know he's building the technology to
emerge so you know uh look at the
actions uh not just the words but well I
mean there's some degree where being
concerned maybe using human psychology
being concerned about threats all around
us as a
motivator like uh it's an encouraging
thing I operate much better when there's
a deadline the fear of the deadline like
and I for myself create artificial
things like I I want to create in myself
this kind of anxiety as if something
really horrible will happen if I miss
the deadline I think there's some degree
of of that here because creating AI
That's aligned with humans has a lot of
potential benefits and so a different
way to reframe that is if you don't
you're we're all going to die it just
seems to be a very powerful
psychological
formulation of the goal of creating
human aligned AI I think that anxiety is
good I think like I said I want the the
free market to to create aligned AIS um
that are reliable uh and I think that's
what he's trying to do with uh xai um so
I'm all for it what what I am against is
sort of
um stopping let's say the open source
ecosystem from Tri thriving right by
let's say in the executive order
claiming that open- Source LMS or dual
use Technologies and should be
government controlled then everybody
needs to register their GPU and their
big matrices with the government and I
think that extra uh friction will
dissuade a lot of Hackers from
contributing hackers that could later
become the the researchers that uh make
key discoveries that uh push us forward
right uh including discoveries for AI
safety and so
I think I I just want to maintain
ubiquity of opportunity to contribute to
Ai and and to own a piece of the future
right it can't just be
legislated uh you know behind some wall
where only a few players get to play the
game I mean so the eak movement is often
sort of
caricatured to mean sort of uh progress
and Innovation at all at all cost
doesn't matter how unsafe it is doesn't
matter if it cause a lot of damage you
build build cool as fast as
possible stay up all night with a Diet
Coke uh whatever it
takes I think I guess I don't know if
there's a question in there but how
important to you and what you've seen
the different formulations of eak is
safety is AI
safety I think again I think like if
there was no one working on it I think I
would be a proponent sure of it I think
again our goal is to sort of bring
balance and obviously a sense of urgency
is a useful tool right to make uh
progress it hacks our dopam energic
systems and gives us energy to to work
late into the night I think also having
a higher purpose you're contributing to
right at the end of the day it's like
what am I contributing to I'm
contributing to the growth of this
beautiful machine so that we can seek to
the Stars that's really inspiring that's
also a sort of uh neuro uh hack so
you're saying a safety is important to
you but right now the landscape of ideas
you see is AI safety as a topic is used
more often to gain centralized control
so in that sense you're resisting it as
a proxy for centralized gaining
centralized control yeah I I I I just
think we we have to be careful because
um you know safety is just the perfect
cover for sort of centralization of
power and covering up eventually
corruption I don't I'm not saying it's
corrupted now but it could be uh down
the line and
really if you if you let the argument
run like there's no amount of sort of
centralization of control that will be
enough to ensure your safety there's
always more nine n nines of Peace safety
that you can gain you know
99.99999% safe maybe you want another n
oh please give us full access to
everything you do full surveillance and
and and frankly those that are
proponents of AI safety have proposed
like having a global
panopticon right where you have
centralized perception of everything
going on and to me that just opens up
the door wide open for a sort of Big
Brother 1984 like scenario and that's
not our future I want to live in cuz we
know we have some examples throughout
history when that did not lead to a good
outcome
right